welcome to the video on the introduction
to differential equations what's a
differential well we've been doing
things like you know if i said that y
y is equal to i don't know 3x if we took
the derivative of both sides of this
equation we said one of the notations we
used is we said d y
over dx
is equal to three we took the derivative
of both sides of that
but this you could almost use
differential notation d y is a
differential
and dx is a differential and what does
what does a differential mean a
differential just means an infinitely
small change in y in this case so that's
the differential in y or an infinitely
small change in x so differential it's
like a difference right
when we learned slope we said you know
slope is change in y
over change in x or you could say the
difference in y over difference in x but
once we started taking the slope of
curves we had to make this difference
and this difference approach zero and
that's what a differential essentially
is a differential is a really really
really really infinitely small
difference so what is a differential
equation well it's an equation that in
involves differentials so for example
this is a differential equation this
will be the first example that we solve
d y
over dx
is equal to
x squared plus one
and so how do we solve this differential
equation
well we could there's a couple of ways
you could say you say oh well you know
this is the same thing as f prime of x
if you know y was a function of x and
you just take the anti-derivative of
both sides but let's solve this properly
as a differential equation so you can
actually manipulate these differentials
the same way that you would manipulate
numbers for the most part
and so what can we do here well let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
dx so you get for a very small change in
y
d y
you get
x squared plus one
times a very small change in
dx or another way to say it is for a
very small change in x if you want to
figure out how much does y change you
multiply times x squared plus one
wherever you are on the curve
so what does that do for us well let's
take the anti-derivative of both sides
let's take the integral of both sides
and if you watched all of the videos on
on integration and the definite integral
and area under curve you realize that
an integral is essentially
a sum it's kind of an infinite sum of a
bunch of these infinitely small d y's so
if you if you take
the sum of all of the changes in d y's
you're left with a y on this side of
this equation and you might want to
re-watch all the videos that we did on
integration
and then what is this this is
essentially just this this is the
indefinite integral of x squared plus
one so it's the antiderivative of that
and what's the antiderivative of x
squared plus one
well it's x
to the third
over
3 and we're just doing it we're just
taking the derivative backwards and once
again
watch the videos on the anti-derivative
there's i think eight or nine of them
plus x
and then plus c and where does the c
come from
well we know that when we take the
derivative of a constant it goes to zero
so when you take the antiderivative
we're like well there could have been a
constant there and that's where that
plus c comes from so this is the general
solution
this is the general solution
to this differential equation and that's
something interesting so
with traditional equations the solution
tended to be a number right if i just
told you know y
is you know if i told you let me y is
equal to 2y minus 1 then you'd sort of
just get minus y is equal to -1 you'd
get y is equal to 1. so this is a
traditional equation and your solution
was just a value you solved for the
variable
differential equations are something
different the solution is actually a
function you're saying what function
satisfies this differential equation so
that's something to keep in mind and
right now we're doing very basic
differential equations but that's
something to keep in mind the whole time
you learn differential equations i think
i'll eventually do
a playlist on on essentially uh
an introductory course on differential
equations that you would you would take
at college and and that applies even
when you start doing partial
differential equations et cetera et
cetera it's the solution to a
differential equation is not a number
it is a function
so anyway this was the general solution
to this differential equation and then
if you want the particular solution
people normally give you initial
conditions or they give you
points on the
on the function and then you can
substitute back so in this problem they
said that you know d y d x is equal to x
squared plus one and then they said that
let me switch colors
they said that y is equal to one
at
x is equal to 1 or y is equal to 1 when
x is equal to 1. so we can use this
information now to solve for c how do
you do that well it says y is equal to
1.
so 1 is equal to when x is equal to 1 is
equal to
one-third right one over three one to
the third power over three
plus
one plus c
and let's see what i can do subtract one
from both sides this is becomes zero
subtract one-third from both sides and
you get c is equal to minus one-third so
using these conditions
a point where this function crosses
through we can now give you the
particular solution to this differential
equation
and that is y
is equal to
x to the third over three
plus
x
minus one third and we just solved for
the c and if you don't believe me take
this expression and substitute it here
and you will see that it equals if you
were to take the derivative of y with
respect to x you would see that it
equals x squared plus one let's do
another one
do another one
so it tells us and this is a little bit
more interesting it tells us
it says d y
d y
d x
is equal to x over y
and it says well it has the same
condition so it says y equals 1
at
x equals 1 or when x equals 1 y equals
1. so let's find the function that
satisfies this equation this one's
interesting because we have a x and a y
on the right hand side of this equation
so this kind of looks like something we
got after we did some type of implicit
differentiation but let's see let's see
where we go
so let's do the same thing let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
dx
and so you get
d y
is equal to x over y
dx and let's get
this y over onto the d y side because
it'll be easy to take the
anti-derivative then so we get
y
d y
is equal to
x
dx
now we can take the integral of both
sides of this equation
take the or take the anti-derivative on
this side with respect to y on this side
with respect to
x
i don't know why i did it in brown
so what's the anti-derivative here
well
it is y squared
over
two
and i could put say plus
c some constant well let me do that it
there could be a constant here
i'll call it
i don't know i'll call it c1 we don't
know what that constant is
and that equals
x squared
over two
plus
c two
or some other constant maybe it's the
same number i don't know but we don't
know what either of these are i can i
could rewrite it as let's see what could
i do i could um
well let me let me take the x onto that
side so i would i could have
y squared
over 2
minus
x squared over 2 is equal to
and let me subtract this from that side
so i get the constants on the right hand
side of the equation
c2 minus c1
right i took
just took the c1 put it on the right
hand side took the x squared over 2 put
on the left hand side that's why it's
negative and we didn't know you know
that we said this could be any constant
and this could be any constant so
the difference between two arbitrary
constants could just be a third
arbitrary constant so i'll just rewrite
that as
c
and so the general solution to this
differential equation
is
y squared
over 2
minus
x squared over
is equal to c
and actually let's do something else
just to clean it up a little bit because
once again this could be any constant so
let's multiply both sides of this
equation by 2 and you get y squared
minus x squared is equal to 2 c
well now this is still any constant
number so we could still write this as a
c so we have y squared
minus x squared is equal to c
now let's use our initial conditions to
see what c is
so when y is one so one squared
minus when x is one
one squared is equal to c
well this is one minus one so it's it's
zero right c is equal to 0. so what is
the particular solution to this general
equation to this differential equation
i'll do it in green
it is
y squared
minus x squared is equal to 0 or we
could add x squared to both sides of
that and we could also write it as y
squared is equal to
x squared
now you might be you might be tempted to
take the square root of both sides of
this and say that y is equal to x
and the reason why this would not be
accurate is because
here x could be
x could be minus 2
and y could be plus 2 or vice versa
right so this would satisfy this
equation but it would not satisfy this
equation so be careful when you take
that square root you know you have to
you have to worry about the plus or
minus let's do one more
let's do one more
so this one
says the derivative of y with respect to
x
is equal to
this is the square okay so this is even
a little bit more interesting
this is equal to
the square root of x
over y
the square root of x over y
and it says that y is equal to 4 when x
is equal to 1.
right yep i think i'm reading that right
well we could do this one very similarly
so let's and well let's just do the same
step so multiply both sides equation
times dx so you get dy
is equal to
and i'm i'm actually just to skip a step
i'm going to rewrite square root of x
over squared over y is the square root
of x over the square root of y
and i multiplied both sides of that
times dx
and now let's multiply both sides of
this equation by the square root of y
and i'm just going to rewrite it as
y to the one-half power right that's the
same thing as square root of y
d y is equal to x to the one-half power
dx i just multiplied that there and
rewrote it as y to the one-half
and so what is the anti-derivative of
y to the one half power
well it's just
this plus one so it's y to the three
halves power
y
to the three halves power
and then times the inverse of this
so times two-thirds
or you could have said divided by this
either way and if you're not sure about
this because sometimes it is confusing
with the fractions and whatever else
take the derivative three halves times
two thirds is one and then you subtract
this one from the exponent and you get y
to the one half so that works and of
course we have we kind of go through the
same drill
plus c one is equal to it's gonna be the
same thing on this side two thirds
x to the three halves
plus
c two
and what can we do well let's take the
x to the left hand side of this equation
so we get
two thirds
y to the three halves
minus two thirds
x to the three halves
is equal to c two minus c one which can
we can just rewrite as you know
c
and let's multiply both sides of this
equation by three halves
so these two will become one so you get
y
to the three halves
minus
x to three halves
is equal to
well what's three halves times some
constant c well we didn't even know what
it was we haven't solved for it so we
can still write c i hope that doesn't
confuse you you know three half c we
didn't know what it was so i'm we could
call this c3 and now this is c4 it's a
different constant but we still have to
solve for it and now let's use our
initial conditions so
the initial conditions tell us that four
and they have to be initial conditions
you can kind of just kind of say
conditions or points where we know that
the function the general the the
particular solution to this differential
equation are satisfied
so
four to the three halves
minus one to the three halves
is equal to c what's four to the three
halves so four to the one half is 2 and
then that to the 3 power that's 8
and then 1 to any power but especially
in this case 1 to the square root of 1
is
is 1 and then
to the third power is 1. so 8 minus 1 is
equal to
c
and so c is equal to seven
and so the particular solution of this
differential equation i will do in a
different color and it is
y
to the three
halves
minus
x to the three halves is equal to seven